Syria and Saudi Arabia are resuming
Consular services and flights for the
first time since the 2011 Uprising and
Civil War the Syrian foreign minister is
in Jeddah on the first such visit in
over a decade Faisal mactad met Prince
Faisal Ben Farhan the two discussed
efforts to find a political solution to
the Syrian crisis
now the kingdom supported Syria's
opposition at the beginning of the Civil
War in 2011. it closed its Embassy in
Damascus and expelled the Syrian
Ambassador in 2012 but relations with
Bashar al-assad's government have
improved in recent months Gathering
momentum after Syria's Ally Iran agreed
to restore diplomatic ties with Saudi
Arabia the normalization of ties between
Riyadh and Damascus signals that Syria's
Regional isolation could be nearing an
end
senior political analyst he's joining us
live now from London more one why have
these links between Saudi Arabia and
Syria improved
mostly on pragmatic bases and by the way
in terms of chronology
the Saudi Crown Prince since uh
basically becoming so back in 2015 2017
onward
he basically accepted the fact that
Assad is staying and he said so publicly
that Saudi Arabia understands that Assad
is going nowhere and basically if he
didn't lose uh you know he kind of won
somehow his civil little Civil War and
by 2018 he's already told also the
Syrian opposition that Saudi Arabia
could no longer support it so you could
say that this has been going on for five
years now that Riyadh understood that
they're going to have to come to terms
with the idea that as a the Assad regime
despite its killings and blockchain and
so on so forth is here to stay and the
only reason that they've held back for
so long now is simply because they were
hoping that Assad would distance his
regime from Iran but as you know Saudi
Arabia is doing its own raposhmo with
Iran as of the last few weeks and hence
that condition no longer really apply
and so the road to to more normalization
if you will between the two countries
opened up whenever we see deals like
this no deal we know in the real world
is ever done out pure Good Will there
must be some give and take on both sides
in your assessment what would Syria have
had to give up if you like in order to
facilitate this this meeting this
joining of forces again with Saudi
Arabia
foreign
ly there's going to be certain
conditions but there will not be
preconditions right I mean clearly in
these talks there will be some
understandings about what Syria would be
doing next where uh right and about its
relationship with Iran and uh and how
and where it's going to be dealing with
the armed groups and uh what sort of a
deal would it arrive at in order to
recover sovereignty uh you know over the
country and off when there would be some
form of an electoral process of some
kind right moving forward for for some
form of normalization or I would say I
would call it saving phase but I think
for the time being what is really at
stake for Saudi Arabia is not really
what's going to go inside Syria it's
more about what's going on inside Saudi
Arabia and I think uh for the Saudi
Crown Prince for the Saudi royal family
what's important is basically
disentangling the Kingdom from very is
crises whether it's Iran Yemen and Syria
and others in the region in order to
focus on the internal situation within
and two in order for Saudi Arabia to
recover its Regional wall uh you know as
a traditional power and I think it's
important at this point in time since
it's hosting an Arab League Summit for
Saudi for Saudi Arabia to be taking the
initiative on Syria knowing that all
other countries or most other countries
with exception of the likes of Qatar
Kuwait and others that the rest are
basically normalizing relations with
Syria and hence why not Saudi Arabia
take the initiative in order to once
again you know appear like that of a
leader within the region I want to ask
you about the global context all of this
since the war in Ukraine we've seen
essentially a polarization to some
degree of forces with the U.S on one
side Western forces China Russia and
their forces and of course Iran is an
ally of Russia and and China are we
seeing a point where Saudi Arabia is as
part of its foreign policy taking sides
I think the Saudis like others have gone
hybrid hybrid meaning now they're mixing
and choosing and mixing between various
Regional and Global power so Saudi
Arabia feels uh you know secure enough
to pursue relations with China as well
as the United States as well as with
India and Japan only with Iran as well
as uh you know with Egypt and so on and
so forth so I think Saudi Arabia has
gone hybrid that doesn't feel like it
needs to be in one Camp rather than the
other but also others like Brazil India
South Africa you know we know many
different countries now are also gone
hybrid I think what's interesting in the
context of both Ukraine and Syria is
that Saudi Arabia for a long time held
back also because the United States
you know is opposed if you want to an
organization with asset even though the
Biden Administration like the
administration before it the Trump
Administration failed utterly in Syria
and basically doesn't have a strategy of
any sort so now Saudi Arabia is
basically saying look you don't have a
successful strategy in Syria you're not
doing much for the country we don't have
much to say because since 2018 we
basically admit that that asset is going
to stay so we're basically going to
break with you meaning the United States
and we're going to normalize relation uh
with Assad that's of course in in in in
in tune with uh with Iran in tune with
the rapu small with China and hence you
could say that Saudi Arabia and others
are playing more independent roles
within the region hoping to be able to
take advantage of the various tensions
around the world whether they are
Russians and Americans or Chinese and
Americans Europeans and American or what
have you
senior political analyst Marwan as
always thank you very much indeed